hey cousin tonight I'm making Dominican
spaghetti every time I share my recipe
the comment section is a war zone watch
at your own risk I add two tablespoons
of oil to my popcorn on medium-high heat
I add four cloves of minced garlic red
onion cubanelle or green bell pepper red
bell pepper some olives with its juice
one chicken bouillon tablet black pepper
and oregano then I add a quarter cup of
tomato paste and one and a half cups of
reserved pasta water a little cilantro
and my cooked pasta the classic
spaghetti number eight it looks a little
watery at first but after two minutes of
mixing on a medium low flame it dries
and thickens up like this now you can
add the traditional butter to your
spaghetti but I prefer adding a couple
tablespoons of mayo it's so creamy and
it gives it so much flavor you can say
what you want to say but this moment and
I'ma stand beside them enjoy cousin